and so um I met with Trump he was
fantastic he was super personable
um he basically told me that
um in my speech I'm going to mention you
know this issue and kind of what you've
been dealing with he said I have you a
front row seat you can sit there if you
want you can stand up and wave and then
you can just sit back down but I just
want to let you know I'll be mentioning
it and thank you for everything you're
doing but we talked for probably 10
minutes it was a really cool experience
and so
in his speech I'm sitting at the front
row and he gets to the topic and he goes
uh games where's games come up here so I
had no idea that I was gonna be actually
on stage with him
um so I I went up on stage and I'm sure
people have heard of this
um situation but he went in to kiss me
on the cheek but I thought he was going
to whisper something in my ear and so I
slightly turned my head to hear him
um but when I did that oh my gosh the
media took it and ran with it they were
saying that I was repulsed by him and I
was dodging his kisses on stage and that
he was being extremely creepy and all of
these things that were just so not true
um so that for one opened my eyes to how
the media Works
um you know I saw articles with comments
by me that I never said
um you know they were telling everyone
my feelings which they never asked me my
feelings so how could they gather that
information
um
and so it was a pretty crazy experience
um but really really cool he was super
authentic
um probably exactly how you would
picture him off stage and off cameras uh
that's really how he was so it was a
cool experience yeah that's the
sentiment I have about Trump I don't
know him personally I've covered him
quite extensively but I get I get the
feeling that he just is who he is right
Mike's on Mike's off it just is what it
is
um and you said you believed that to be
an authentic um response by him and
authentic concern he has about this
issue in women's sports I believe that
to be true if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
foreign
[Music]